hi um imagine being the perfect freedom
and all the resources to design a data
pipeline from scratch
how would you do
what would you do
so
i'm going to talk about how we created
our data pipeline for
and what decisions we had to make while
building it i will start a very brief
introduction
and i'm going to move on to why why we
needed it
so my name is gabor i received my
masters from the university of oxford
i worked for systematic hedge fund for a
couple of years before joining optiverse
quant research teams
my main duties are
building systematic trading strategies
and also building this pipeline
acetaminous
data scientists
data engineers
fellow researchers and traders and
together we form this constant feedback
loop while trying to improve our
decision making
we are highly data-driven
so quantitative methods predictions are
the
at the forefront of what we do
optiver has been around for 36 years
and why is data important for us so we
started with a single trader in the
amsterdam's options exchange and this is
where traders had to use hand gestures
and shout to get information across
traders were monitoring with our eyes
and ears just to see like what trace
just happened how to react to them they
were very good at maths mental
arithmetics to see like based on what
positions they had what positions they
want to get into
we traded only a couple of instruments
back then
and most of the things were not
automated
so if you wanted to expand you had to
hire smart math wizards train them up on
how trading is done put them into this
trading pit and this was a very slow and
gradual process
over the years things have changed
electronic exchanges introduced a new
way of trading which brought a new set
of challenges but also the opportunities
to
to automate things
on an average day we make around 3
million trades on over 100 000
instruments and all of this with just
maybe 150 traders
so the scaling to more instruments is
now happening on how fast you can make
decisions
and so we are enabling our traders to to
make better decisions faster by this
automation
the main reason
um
like i was wondering if you could
estimate the number of data we get every
minute
anyone
okay so we are connected to over 50
exchanges
and this is raw data so this is just
price
time series it's about 100 gigabytes
so for a normal human with a reading
speed of 250 words per minute it would
take around 100 126 years to to process
this data that we receive in a minute so
clearly automation was necessary for us
to to progress forward
the data requirements for automation and
predictive analysis with complex models
required some advancements also to our
data pipelining
so
here comes the
why
why question why build a data pipeline
for ourselves our previous data pipeline
started to become outdated
and we were trying to scale up to more
underlyings
meaning more products that we are
trading like tesla stock or other
options
and with more and more complex models
because we wanted to achieve better
prediction
so
we started timing out on database
queries
the number of calls that we sent to
databases also sometimes brought down
replication servers
so we were in constant need
of optimizing and re-optimizing our code
just in order to maintain the update
frequency of the predictions that we had
to produce
so one of our trading teams alone needs
5000 plus predictions in every minute so
this is kind of the scale that we are
talking about here
so what we needed
was
something that was accessible for a wide
wide group of people
we wanted to
enable our traders who are less tech
savvy to be able to write scripts just
as well as data analysts data engineers
and other quants
we needed something that was able to
produce results
that matched
the live
so making it in production and the back
test performances
we also needed something that was
scalable to large computational graphs
some of our production graphs have over
10 000 edges
and
sorry
when we're looking into existing
solutions
we realize that
there is no one thing fits all
it's
not not easy to to find a solution
readily available
because the design choices
are very much influenced by by your use
cases
so
we looked at a lot of different tools
and we picked ideas but we could not
just overwrite one of them we had to
go from the ground up because it would
have taken us maybe even longer time to
rebuild one of the existing solutions
at times
it could be quite difficult
to to sell a product like this to
existing teams that are already working
with a different pipeline
and
yeah it's it's it's one of those things
that
sorry i'm too busy i don't i don't know
please next time i will have a look at
it
but this this tool that we have built
has has made big enough waves that
currently our our main dev is in chicago
discussing how we can make it into a
global
global tool so yeah we we because we
designed it ourselves
we made the
trade-offs between the latency needs we
had
the consistency between the code and the
logic and the
and the the data
so
how it works and why it works
we have designed it entirely in python
so each script we write uses a set of
nodes
with relational mapping between them
and this forms a dag
so this is a directed acyclic graph
quite common in the industry
we specify our features as as sub graphs
and have an elimination of of common
nodes so you have the subgraph
elimination to
to not having to recompute something
that you've already done
each node is part of the main graph and
has an understanding of what it relies
on
so
it will only compute
once all its upstream nodes have
computed
we use an event loop
async and multiprocessing to take care
of
i o and heavy computationally nodes
so for those of you like if you you
can't really see it really well but
there is some writing in these notes
these are the hashes that we produce for
for them
and i will come back to it when i'm
talking about the the caches
of these
um and secondly this is a simplified
version of of some some of the large
nodes and those systems that we have
but because we have over 10 000 edges it
just
would look like a mass
the upstream nodes
the orange colored ones
are the raw data input nodes
these usually read data from either a
historical database or a bus in our case
a redis server
and they could be specified as easily as
any other node these are our connection
to the real world and and the the data
the blue nodes are derived nodes they
usually have at least one upstream node
and this could be anything from simple
transformations
like a log transformation of a feature
or
as complex as a complete regression
algorithm could be any machine learning
algorithm you you can imagine
and the final node
at the bottom here is
what we call the sync could be the root
but i don't want to get into terminology
issues because you can call either this
a leaf or the top of the leaf so yeah
let's just not get into it so this is
the sink and usually this is going to be
what we produce and
this can be stored in a live database
each node that that we construct
produces an infinite time series so they
are endless
and you can pull them forward in time so
if you run a script live you can say get
me as off this time and it will
signal all the way upstream
and it will it will move everything
forward to that timestamp
because we can have different resolution
nodes you can have them at milliseconds
seconds minutes or even like couple of
days frequencies
we specify them as calendars and when
these different frequency nodes have to
interact
we decided that we need to use something
special an up sampling or down sampling
for them and this interaction happens at
one of these
child nodes
we also put in a hybrid caching system
which i will come back to a little bit
later
and so why does it work
and why it works for us it's been
designed from the ground up with our
needs in mind
which means
looking at very short-term predictions
on financial time series
it allows us to write scripts very
easily no need to write low level c code
so it's very accessible to people
and it's fast enough for our human
latency needs which means
on a second to 10 seconds level i'm able
to produce predictions from complex
models
and overall like moving on from our old
pipeline to this new one it has allowed
us to make predictions
from raw data to predictions from a
couple of minutes down to sub 10 seconds
this was one of the larger projects that
we have worked on and because of this we
had a lot of going back and forth
between the business owners
developers traders just to understand
their needs
and these talks ended up with a lot of
questions as you can imagine how do you
do this what why would you do that how
can we design it better
and so what i wanted to talk today is
the general theme
of these questions and the answers that
we come up for them
so could you think of a couple of
questions that you would have if you had
to design
a data pipeline yourself
i will
i will go through a couple of
semantic ones
so
the first couple are design related
and they relate to
why you should write
code that is used by both the live and
the historical
how do you speed up the research to
production cycle
and how do you ensure that what you have
run in your back tests
is going to be
the same performance in live
environments so in your production
the second group is
how fast does it need to be
do we need something as low latency as
in nanoseconds or do we want something
that gives us some convenience
to be able to use python as the back end
next question was data that is arriving
asynchronously what do we do with this
how can we deal with it
and the final set of questions are all
related to resource management and
caching
so
how do you reduce the number of queries
you have to make
how can you speed up the day-to-day
research
and what do you do with the stateful
nodes
so
should you write code that is used by
both live and historical pipelines
we are going to tackle this from both a
general and a research perspective
let me start with a quick story so a
couple of months ago i had to
move our python36
built library into python39 and i
thought everything was going fine until
we hit production we had a lot of bugs
that were not covered by unit tests and
you only realize it when you actually
have to upgrade your packages that
something under the hood has changed
so obviously this is a python to python
conversion and only python library is
being updated
but still some some things can go wrong
now imagine the same thing happening if
you are doing it between python and
a different low-level language that
doesn't have any of your packages
so
it's not trivial
for a research to production perspective
writing code once enabled us to
replicate live behavior in back testing
which boosted confidence
in our
strategies
and this way also we avoided any logic
translation bugs inherent in this
moving from one package to the next
etc so writing code once enabled us to
do all of this
and also with writing once you don't
have any of this research to production
cycle it's practically the same you
write it once you use it in both
environments so the research
and the production are identical you
don't have any mismatches
there is however also an opportunity to
reflect on the other side of this coin
because
writing separate code for research and
production can also be a viable
opportunity for
something that needs to be more speedy
that python can offer so there are
definitely use cases where you want
to have this flexibility which enables
you to to write performant code for your
production purposes but you want your
researchers to
to be
surrounded with the packages that they
are all familiar with
for us it just wasn't an option we we
need the live and the
back test frameworks to match
perfectly otherwise you don't know what
trades you are making and it's just very
dangerous
so moving on
how fast does it need to be
we at optivar we are market makers which
usually people will associate with high
frequency trading
and collocations
but this is not what we are going to
talk about today what what i'm referring
to is the human latency the the seconds
latency
and for example this could be
dashboarding applications or
non-event-driven
predictions
so a quick question would be would you
rather spend your time rebuilding the
python data stack
on the
drive from scratch right
or spend your time on tools that are
not so readily available or really far
from your potential
optimal use cases
when we asked our researchers the answer
was unanimous please
let me use all these libraries which
have thousands of devs backing them i
want to be able to use this nice pi data
stack
this doesn't mean that
you can write bad code you
still need to write performant code
and so
we do whatever it takes to speed up the
core of the library in the core of this
data pipeline
and we utilize a lot of these uh nice
packages like number saturn sometimes we
have to wrap some c code just just to
enable us to to do something faster we
try and vectorize everything so numpy
one of our closest friends with with the
raw data nodes in place you also want to
use something like async
so you don't have i o blocking issues
you also want to use multi-processing so
some of your computationally intensive
nodes don't like don't hold all the
resources and and block your
computational graph
okay
what traders do we make when the input
data arrives asynchronously
in some traditional etli framework so
jenkins or crontab
you might carry a table at a certain
time let's say at time x
and you make the assumption that all the
data is up to date by that time
okay this assumption might work for for
some applications but i will give you an
example where it clearly breaks
so let's assume that you are trading two
stocks and these stocks are very
codependent so they move up and down
together
and then
when they really
move apart
like one of them prints a much larger
number than the other okay you sell
the better performing one and buy the
lower performing one and bet on the
convergence of the two so this is a very
basic strat spread trading
strategy
and suppose everything ticks at the same
rate you have updates every second or
every 20 second doesn't really matter
for for this
but for some reason your database
connection or some raw market link goes
down and for stock b you're not
receiving data for a minute
and in this minute markets are very busy
probably why your market link went down
and so it just happens that
stock a has printed a large value
and since you assume that the data is
still correct you have this forward
field value of nothing happening to b so
now you're selling a and buying b
betting on the convergence
all good right
so
now suppose that b actually comes back
alive the market link survived and the
data
shows that actually b printed a much
larger value so the trade you should
have made was selling b
and not a
you're on the wrong side of the trade
so this is clearly a completely
hypothetical scenario but it
demonstrates the problem that we might
be facing in finance when the data is
arriving asynchronously
it doesn't really need to be that the
market link or whatever raw data is not
arriving on time it also could be that
you make a query through your database
or one of your computational nodes is
not running on time
so how do we deal with this what do we
do we say we are rather still than wrong
so we wait until
the latest data is available for all the
underlyings
and this this just made sense to us
maybe for other purposes it doesn't make
sense
so in our deck design how we ensure this
is that once once a node at the bottom
requests
is requested to produce a new value it
goes all the way upstream and on the raw
data we have this blocking
and until the raw data has arrived you
can't compute the downstream
so this is a very easy way of doing it
now i have to mention that you obviously
will have nodes with different
update frequencies you can have nodes
that are regressions that you don't want
to retrain every minute
you might have them update every week
so what do you do if you want to predict
that every 10 seconds are you going to
block now for a whole week just because
oh the regression is not up to date
please wait
right you wouldn't do it so this is
where this up and down sampling has to
happen you can have
nodes that are at much higher frequency
updated like at milliseconds and you can
combine them with the daily data that
that
you just need to build a logic around it
so
how do we deal with resource management
the simple dag represents a hypothetical
dependency graph
and
at the top we have the the raw data the
the upstream inputs to where we are
fetching
market data let's say prices
and the trades that just happened
the the middle layer is going to be some
transformations on this data and could
be some regression or a backtester
framework
and so on the first run let's say this
is
a very very simplified version of a
backtester this is how a backlasher
looks like
so
i go i fetch all my data it could be a
lot of data it could be gigabytes of
queries coming through
then i have some computational nodes
that have to compute some very stateful
outputs like position vectors that
change over time
and finally is my backtest results which
is going to give me how good performing
is my strategy
now
i forgot to do something
one of my nodes had the wrong logic i
need to modify something or i'm just
running multiple of these strategies and
i just don't have the resources to run
them parallel so what can i do obviously
you don't want to run it parallel either
because you are just going to download
the data all over the place so
what do you do well we didn't cache
anything so i have to go back download
the raw data
complete the states produce
not ideal
so what i do
i just replicated it and i add node
agnostic caching so what does that mean
so most of these nodes are loading data
from from databases and producing some
outputs these outputs are usually
something nice like
data frames
so you can store them down in hdf or
whatever tickles your pickle
and you you can go all the way down and
and get the root note
and now the second run i'm way faster
because i don't have to load the data
because i can just use these node
agnostic caches i make the assumption
that the raw data didn't change
but i can literally reach my end results
instead of hours in probably a couple of
minutes
i
deliberately left out a couple of edges
without the green
and these are potentially the nodes
where you don't want to cache
and there could be two reasons for this
the first main reason is you are using
them
and you are modifying
the logic inside so you are running
separate different maybe a grid search
and it just doesn't make sense because
whatever you're going to cash down is
never going to be used again
or you are using something that is super
fast to compute and loading it from the
data is going to be just slower than
actually doing it this way
so overall
no caching not an option you have to do
some kind of caching for us
and this node exhausting caching seems
to work it's perfect right
well
not quite moving on from the historical
testing
to real-time computations so production
there are certain things that won't work
running the scripts by starting them up
making them compute publish and then
exit
works really well for the back testing
and for lightweight scripts
however for others this this cycle that
you you have to keep like waking them up
while not waking them up starting them
up again
it just doesn't work the startup cost
could be expensive and the computation
of some of the states could be just
prohibitive for your use cases
even if the update frequency is just
like 10 seconds
the the state computation alone
can be too slow like what i mentioned
earlier the position vectors they are
really part dependent and that means
that you might at times have to
go through a month or couple of months
of data simulate through it just to land
on the same timestamp on the previous
timestamp at the same position as you
had in in the previous run
so these are very expensive computations
and you don't want to deal with this
so in summary the the node agnostic
caching kind of works because it helps
loading all that history called data
it's already cached for us and you can
just append to it it's nice but for live
scripts there is still something missing
the the state itself
so does this mean that you have to cache
the state
for of each
node
i think we have found like a nice
quick win
and this is
staying alive
so
what does this mean you have a cycle
that is very very close to our previous
one but instead of exiting
so you make the publish you you publish
your your prediction or whatever your
output is
you turn you're going to sleep
and you have something that orchestrates
a wake up at certain times of your
script
and so how does this help us
this allows us to keep
state in memory
so it
speeds up this whole cycle
because you don't have to do any of this
computation anymore
when my
my
event loop says oh please wake up now
fetch me the recent data pull everything
forward in time
all i have to do is very small
incremental computation
and this allows us to really make
predictions at some 10 seconds
for quite complex models
now obviously
things can go wrong
what if the script crashes
or i am running this during the day
but i realize that there is a bug
i need to i need to redeploy something
so in these cases
well we have fallen short of this
promise of of this in-memory cache
and what we need to do in these cases is
really no specific caching
and there are multiple different ways of
doing this you can put them on a
separate server you can keep them
locally depending on how how reusable
these state caches are
but once you've done this once you have
put all of these node diagnostic caching
running them live and this state caches
there's not much that you can slow you
down
so in summary
we don't have
we need the no diagnostic caching for
the historical testing and the in-memory
caching can speed up a lot
and
the state specific caches of the nodes
can can actually help you bring up the
cycle much quicker
so in summary bringing it all together
going back to what we really needed and
how we have achieved this so
we wanted an easy to use by a large
variety of backgrounds we wanted traders
to use it as easily as our quan devs
written in python for accessibility and
also the convenience you have all the
pipelines or sorry pipelines you have
all the pi data stack available to you
it's it produces perfect match because
yeah you have written it once and it's
scalable to large computational graphs
so what we have learned is writing once
and using everywhere it has really
provided us with this nice framework so
you don't have to
worry about your back test mismatching
your production
you don't have logic translation bugs
anymore
the research to production cycle speeds
up massively we used to write stuff in
python then translate into
some low-level code
it takes some time it takes developer
effort
trading part of speed for convenience it
has allowed us this easy to use yet
enough for our human latency need
framework
and so we managed to eliminate a lot of
duplicate efforts from different teams
trying to write their own features all
the time
everything is centralized everything is
easy to use we gave access to pretty
much
anyone who knows basic scripting
being still rather than wrong it has
simplified our trading logic you don't
have to write separate scripts or what
happens if
x is
not updated what happens if y is not
updated you might have dispersion models
compromising of multiple products
and and these dependencies can be very
very cumbersome so
it just simplified our complete logic
and staying alive aka the hybrid caching
has allowed us to
to speed up
our our predictions from a couple of
minutes to sub 10 seconds for even
super complex models and we can now do
it for thousands of underlyings at the
same time
so
we can do this
and much bigger
thank you and that's it
thank you gabor
is there any question
from audience
oh many questions let's start here then
i walk back
oh yeah thanks for that um one of your
reasons for data arriving asynchronously
was because like a node takes a long
time to complete
um
i can sort of see a scenario where
if you're is it sync no the green ones
the the ones yeah uh
if it refuses to produce an output
because an upper node is uh taking a
long time to complete like you can see a
scenario where yeah you just you end up
not producing the outputs like what what
do you have a mechanism for that or has
it occurred yeah so the
what you're asking is essentially so
what do you do when actually one of your
nodes is slow and and it's it's not
updating as as it should be
it's annoying right so this is where you
go back to the drawing board okay maybe
i need to re-optimize some of these
notes because it's a different
perspective being still rather than
wrong it means that okay i might at some
times have to slow down and produce an
output at a later stage
because i just can't feasibly produce to
something that is completely correct
and this is clearly a trade-off for some
use cases this is
inefficient you won't react as soon as
one of your inputs has has arrived and
for our cases most of the time
this wasn't the case we wanted something
to be completely correct
uh hi thank you for the talk i would
like to ask if the quants need to
uh
be aware of the structure or the api of
the of the computing system uh
especially is there if there is any kind
of algorithmic restrictions on what they
can implement depending on a batch or an
online algorithm you we know that not
every batch algorithm can be turned into
an online algorithm how do they resolve
this yeah so
it's pretty pretty much building blocks
so the the api is is very free to use
it's essentially we have all the raw
data available and there are some nodes
that are more complex than others
some of these we
require devs to to build and then we can
give these to the researchers so it's
not a streamlined process for everything
but for most easy easy to use tasks when
you ask a trader oh i have an idea but i
don't have the time to implement it for
you
okay this is this is where i can teach
them okay look this is python you can
specify your input nodes these are the
raw data nodes
you specify what features you want you
specify what type of machine learning
algorithm you want and then i can output
you a prediction
this could be very simple as well you
don't need predictions you could make
just some transformations from data and
construct something for your
dashboarding so you can see some
meaningful features that
you obviously couldn't do before
so it we can talk later as well it's
it's not always straightforward
hi thanks for the talk i just had two
questions uh
the first one's related to the live
versus back testing alignment
um so it sounds like the pipeline and
the
kind of
buying selling decision code are both
written in python
what kind of implications does that have
on latency and execution and that kind
of thing like how can you ensure that
the live and the back test are the same
when
presumably in the live setting the the
latency matters a lot
indeed so
obviously what i was presenting here is
one of the many pipelines that we have
at optivar
when it's really latency sensitive
we have a much lower level library
for for our human latency needs it means
that you have the time usually to to be
able to react on top of it
so i can give you an example so if if
you're treating as frequently and you're
turning over only once an hour does it
really matter that you have executed it
at a millisecond level or does it really
matter whether you have done it in a
first couple of minutes there might be
small back tests and live mismatches
because of the execution of the trades
but that doesn't mean that you have
complete disparity between them the
logic is the same if you automate the
execution it should be the same
but
there is clearly this assumption that
you making back tests that you can run
at certain frequencies and you have
perfect hedges at the right time
etc okay that makes sense um
yeah the second question was just
thinking about the caching system
um is the caching system kind of like
keyed by
by two time dimensions kind of like an
as of and seen from like what happens
yeah yeah i i forgot to mention this but
one of the the key
inputs to this was
okay when do we break the the cache hash
and essentially we come down to
actually looking at the whole logic of
the node and we hash that
but obviously the node itself doesn't
really know about its parents
changing
so we actually hash all the parents all
the way up
and everything is hashed together and
then
whatever hash we have
we store with that
and if something is changing upstream
the whole
dependency graph from that node
downstream will have to recompute
so this could happen like i modified one
of my hyper parameters and because of
that my regression changes because of
that my some back test inputs change so
everything downstream from there has to
recompute so this is where
okay there there could be one more
iteration on top of this
which is when you are looking at raw
data changing under your feet usually
you wouldn't assume that historical data
will not change but sometimes somebody
inputted the wrong data you have you get
the modification now you reload it and
you get a different output
so
if you don't break the the cache
on that
you're going to get different results
later on
so there is a trade-off you can then
specify that please recompute this node
and if you recompute it
then everything downstream will
recompute as well
okay cool thanks
any more questions
no
then
let's think there was one more yeah
sorry
um
i understand
that
probably most of your nodes and the data
that you work with are time series right
yes are there any nodes that have non
time series c or numerical data
there are but i can't really talk about
them
okay
is it like is it just i guess
categorical uh some sort of
could be
sorry
okay
so let's thank gabor again for the talk
you